North Korea is looking to capture the
world's attention as it puts on what can
be described as a parade for the ages to
celebrate its 70th anniversary just
months after summoning reporters to
witness the destruction of a nuclear
test site the country is looking to make
another powerful statement Ben Tracy is
in Pyongyang the North Korean capital
this morning
Ben good morning north Korea has invited
more than 100 journalists and thousands
of tourists from all over the world to
come here to Pyongyang this weekend for
these major events that it plans to put
on to celebrate its founding day now
that does include a major military
parade through the streets of Pyongyang
the big question is whether Kim jong-un
will show off the intercontinental
ballistic missiles that North Korea
claims are capable of hitting the United
States
he says he's serious about
denuclearization and has recently tried
to appear less confrontational
so not parading the ICBMs may be a sign
of goodwill now since we arrived here
the North Koreans have wanted to show us
another side of their country taking us
to a teaching College where young women
are being trained as elementary school
teachers and also to a cosmetics factory
in recent months Kim Jong moon has
really stressed to his people that he
wants to focus on education and growing
North Korea's economy now the reality of
course is that North Korea still has all
of its nuclear weapons and there has
been little progress in trying to
convince Kim jong-eun to give them up
for CBS this morning Saturday Ben Tracy
Pyongyang North Korea